la conversation a été très constructive les mères
tout le sauna avant de mourir un caissier
le côté du camion l'axe de la recherche blasik cost
monsieur le père
[la musique]
il en résulte que le plus grand nombre
les cyberattaques dans le monde sont menées avec
nous cyberespace
creusant tout au long de 2020, nous
envoyé et nous avons reçu nous demandes 10
enquêtes sur les cyberattaques sur un objet
de l'ombre mais les états d'amérique comme on dit
nos collègues du cyberespace russe
et deux demandes de ce genre cette année pour tout
d'entre eux l'année dernière et cette année notre
collègues ont reçu des réponses exhaustives
Erica a récemment rencontré
les non-événements les plus durs après le connu
événements après le meurtre d'un Afro-Américain
et créer tout un mouvement comme aime-moi
fais
nous sympathisons avec les Américains et
Américain mais on n'en veut pas
s'est passé dans notre région
ici avec des revendications politiques
entré au congrès américain après les élections 400
homme excitation portiv 400 personnes
un dossier criminel
ils risquent une peine de prison pouvant aller jusqu'à 20a
peut-être 25 ans les annonce
terroristes nationaux
[la musique]
Je veux délibérément le souligner.
ignorant cette exigence de la loi ce
le monsieur est parti à l'étranger pour se faire soigner
à propos de ce qu'il est venu, je pars du fait que
voulait
consciemment allé être
détenu il a fait ce qu'il voulait
en ce qui concerne les engagements
Ukraine, nous n'avons qu'une seule obligation
contribuer à la mise en œuvre du Minsk
accords si la partie ukrainienne
prêt pour cela nous allons passer par là
sans aucun doute
[la musique]
évaluation tomasz nagieva nuit
et Joukov Léon Tolstoï a dit un jour à la vie
il n'y a pas de bonheur, il n'y a que des éclairs
les chérir, il me semble que dans un tel
la situation ne peut être
la confiance de la famille mais me l'éclaire
semble avoir clignoté
[la musique]